I'm Doug Walker and I'm Rob Walker and
we still don't have microphones but the
show must go on
this is sibling right the ships dead
sucker she's gone no she's not no ship
should go down without a cap to the
alternate Adventures of the USS
Enterprise continue in star trek into
darkness Kirk and the team are back to
go up against a new enemy played by
Benedict Cumberbatch
but as they continue on their journeys
they find out their secrets within
secrets all sorts of little tricks up
everybody's sleeve and of course
adventure and action ensues star trek
into darkness being a Star Trek fan
myself like in the movies and a lot of
the shows is among one of the better
Star Trek films to come out it has a lot
of great action it has great character
it has great story it's smart it's
clever it has good twist it has some
wonderful effects which is why it is so
heartbreaking when Star Trek fans have
to sit through the last 15 minutes of
this film which almost makes it all not
worth it Star Trek movies have made a
lot of mistakes in the past this is
among one of the worst if not the worst
yes it is that bad it reach Fred's
territory that doesn't need to be
retreaded because the new films have
been doing so well just being their own
thing and continuing the legacy that did
not need to pointlessly go back to
something that makes a cliche that makes
it formulaic that makes it sappy that
makes it silly that makes it so
ridiculous it almost destroys the whole
thing but not for me thankfully the film
is still very clever and very smart
unbelievably entertaining throughout the
rest of the film if you can just forget
the last 15 minutes happen and even the
incredibly rush epilogue that follows it
I still highly recommend it for Star
Trek fans who will just have to cringe
throughout the last few minutes and even
people who are not fans of Star Trek who
will enjoy it and probably think nothing
in the last 15 minutes how about you I
hold on one second
I can feeling yeah it was a pretty tough
and big to get through wait oh my god um
okay you know I'm gonna need enough we
won't spoil it we won't actually say why
HAP it will do I like what we did last I
will have a spoiler corner going into
more detail so we will not ruin I need a
couple of swigs cuz I feel like I'm
gonna be like kicking my own kid or
kicking a puppy or something like I have
to hurt something I love because it's
like a baseball game and it's like
watching your home team they're battling
just battling for their lives and
they're playing flawlessly and perfectly
and you're like we got this we got this
one inning left to go we got it and then
they blow it and it was such a great
film up until that point which is why I
just hate having to slap it around
because a team that should have known
better a tomb that I think in that
confidence in itself and I don't it had
and it and it needed that confidence
they had throughout the rest of the
movie cuz it was doing so great they had
a fantastic villain good character
development I had a number of role
reversals switching roles around from
what happened in the original series
there's an interesting political subtext
we're finally getting to the core of the
matter which is is Starfleet a military
organization or is it sort of a
political peacekeeping force with both
these films it seems to be that they get
so much of it well done and they keep so
much of in my opinion very true to Star
Trek because I think they do capture
these characters and they put up my new
journeys and put them in different which
was always the key to Star Trek was the
character but there always seems to be
one major flaw in each of them with this
one it's the ending with the first one
is the villain yeah the first one and we
so traded up on villains this time and I
know it's wonderful Eric Bana is Nero
okay I love Nero only because of how
cheesy it is hi Christopher I'm Nero
this villain incredible meticulously
acted legitimately frightening and
threatening I mean there are scenes that
are like something out of silence and
lambs where the motion coming out of him
I'm like you're crazy
it makes it a little bit more
complicated as well that there's a film
but there's also kind of another villain
too and you get into that argument of
which one is sort of the lesser evil
here and it's a tough argument it's it's
a really tough call I mean in the end
you kind of look at it as like and this
is where the political subtext I thought
was actually really brilliant
particularly in a post-911 setting was
where are we drawing the line when we
start making deals with the devil you
know in at what point you know are we
the villains are you know can we
distinguish anymore is it a thin grey
line and what I like about this too is
that everything in Star Trek p'tee
really won the deal with like the
Starfleet elements you know everything
is you know by-the-book Indian of course
Kirk always goes against the book but
he's always shunned for it now you sir
see Starfleet going against the book and
being quiet you're nobody's supposed to
know about this we're going to be doing
something Elia cuz Pike and the rest are
yelling at Kirk at the beginning for
breaking rules and you know this starts
to become an interesting thing that
happens in the movie it was like is
Starfleet always on the level here um
it's a good moral dilemma between Kirk
and start we're interesting thing is
like once I start getting feedback from
people who said some things are just
glossed over like Kirk does something
stupid in the beginning and he violates
Starfleet regulations I'm like do you
not rec watch the original series
I thought the introduction which was
sloppily handled from an action
perspective his very Raiders of Lost Ark
really was not that out of place though
on the grand sort of Star Trek glory
it's it comes down to a moral ethical
dilemma you know in the basics of it is
it comes back yeah either they come on
my bad calmly which was brilliant um and
you know it's the question he has like I
can do something right but it's breaking
the rules and like I've seen complaints
it's like well he's still immature I'm
like not really he's immature in my
opinion in the fact that he's not
considering the ramifications for his
crew which is a lesson he learns during
this movie which i think is part of his
maturing process but it's not as
immature because what he's doing
he's doing from what he feels is right
in his heart as this is a moral right
just choice I'm making to save a number
of people his issue as always is that he
doesn't always think it through and as
Pike says like you get saved sometimes
by dumb luck I was worried when they
started off with that I was like are we
gonna regress these characters cuz I'm
gonna be pissed I'm like no I actually
they didn't it seems like it sort of
picked up where it left off I'm like
okay he still has some immaturity but
now it's being molded into something
like I believe that you know Starfleet
should be doing something that's morally
right you know I'm gonna break the rules
because I feel like Starfleet's not
accounting for things like this and
there's no right or wrong answer to that
which is the brilliance of that opening
I can see it either way I'm like I can
make an argument that Kirk is dead wrong
and I can make an organism no maybe he's
right
and what I like about Star Trek in
general is that it seems to especially
recently it seems to like to take
extremes that characters like to take
and it likes to question those extremes
you know very much it's just not even
right or wrong just by the book or you
know a Kirk's not always right
Starfleet's not always our x-pipe spots
not always right and is trying to find
that balance that's all of them
interacting off each other which again I
think is why it's so strong with the
characters because they all are such
extremes you know the Vulcan is extreme
logic and Kirk is extreme rule breaker
and risk-taker and ethical and and human
somebody was like all the characters in
the Abrams and are all just cardboard
cutouts and click cliched and like
cartoon cares I disagree
in my opinion Star Trek started off as
stereotype it did oh why can't they have
evolved their dream there are two
characters in the original Trek I think
got around that early on whether by
accident or writing or acting and that
is Nichols as Ahura and Takei as Sulu
outside of him fencing in a couple of
goofy things they came off with a lot of
dignity I think they're confusing the
fact that it has youthful energy and
action sequences agreed and not always
directed well I think they're looking at
that as somehow well that means it's
different and skipping over the fact
that there's actually a lot of character
a lot of interesting ideas a lot of
moral dilemmas brought up but because
they have a fistfight somewhere in the
middle which I guess the original series
never did
I actually think some of the action
sequences particularly at the end
there's a scene where the ship is going
down to the planet gravity gravity and
they're literally walking on the sides
of the wall or on the ceilings as really
ending around hammocks I mean nothing
that brilliant let's star trek six with
the Klingons all floating and the
assassination sequence and so much very
brilliant I mean and I I think we can
agree we love it we start a fire and the
strategy and the hiding and the I do de
Souza's are in warfare wise but you do
it not it we've seen that so much and
it's what I want to do something
different and they died doing something
different there say hey we have this
universe what can we do with this
universe with this ship with this
technology and they give and adjust it
so fits within the context of the
original series because if you look at
the original series versus the movies
that came out in the 80s it has sort of
a kinetic energy more in the original
series than it does later later became
more in the Nikolas Myers mould of
submarine warfare these are slow ships
moving the the original series when the
ships in warp it's always look kind of
silly a dangerous wing and like you know
they managed to capture that with modern
special effects and give it that
youthful energy bag and if there's one
other thing that I really want to give
Abrams and his special effects team and
his storyboard artists everything credit
and thank God for this it's the fact
that they understood another key thing
about Trek is that the enterprise is a
character and whenever you see the ship
in the beginning of this movie when the
ship launches when the ship is in
trouble it has a weight it has a
character you feel like it's really
there and the best Trek films always did
that the last thing I'll bring up before
we should probably start wrapping it up
here is that you were talking about a
lot of people didn't like how young
everybody was an Allen man when I heard
they were doing this reboot I saw the
pictures of the cast I was skeptical too
but I had to give great they picked good
young actors and the same thing with the
Ville and they picked a good younger
actor to do this and they earn it I
remember a good scene from every one of
the main Star Trek cast and that's
really good I really employ me oh this
Scotty was just embarrassing
embarrassing I couldn't disagree more
I thought you actually I thought big
Simon Pegg was excellent
and they're the scenes get emotional
near the end and honestly the only time
I choked up was with Simon Pegg as Star
Trek fans we really loved this movie up
until the last 50 minutes I'd say if
you're not a Star Trek fan you prior to
find like a fun little adventure
honestly if you've not seen much if you
see nothing of Star Trek except the
first Abrams film you'll probably like
it all of the space battles were
interesting before the ending all of the
major space set pieces and what they do
were original the comedy worked really
well I thought most good Trek films have
some aspect of comedy which is nice if
you're just like I couldn't stand the
ending and ruin the whole movie for me I
totally get that
it's I don't know if it did for me but I
completely understand where you're
coming from but I think regardless
there's a lot to appreciate know and a
lot to recommend in it so uh take that
for what it's worth I'm Spock and I'm
not hey we'll see you next time take
care